>> MORE DIRE ECONOMIC WARNINGS
WERE PRESIDENT BIDEN AS
INFLATION KEEPS.
PRICES HAVE GONE UP 5 PERCENT
THAT'S THE FASTEST PACE IN 2008.
ALL THOSE UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS
THAT THE GOVERNMENT HAS JUST
BEEN DISHING OUT?
ANY REPORTS AS CRIMINALS HAVE
STOLEN ABOUT HALF OF ALL THAT
MONEY SINCE THE PANDEMIC STARTED
.
IT ADDS UP TO ALMOST
$400 BILLION, MOST OF IT GOING
TO CRIME SYNDICATES IN CHINA AN
RUSSIA.
THIS IS BAD NEWS, BUT ALMOST
COMPLETELY UNSURPRISING THAT
THAT MUSCAT THAT GOES OUT THE
DOOR THAT QUICKLY, WITHOUT ANY
SAFEGUARDS IS THEN TAKEN OVER
USING RAN SOMEWHERE AND OTHER
DARK WEB TECHNIQUES.
>> I THINK THIS IS AN ABSOLUTE
TRAVESTY.
THIS IS A BREACH OF THE PUBLIC
TRUST AND I KNOW PEOPLE, I KNOW
ONE WOMAN IN PARTICULAR IN NEW
JERSEY WAS LAID OFF IN JANUARY,
SHE HAS YET TO BE ABLE TO GET
THROUGH TO THE UN- APPOINTMENT
OFFICE AND SHE'S LIVING AT HOME
NOW, SHE WANTS TO WORK, SHE'S
TRYING TO GET A JOB AND MAKE
THINGS HAPPEN AND YOU CANNOT
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO GET THE
UNEMPLOYMENT OFFICE TO CALL YOU
BACK BUT CRIMINALS CAN FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO GET THAT MONEY AUN
IN THE MEANTIME WE HAVE THE FBI
FIGURING OUT HOW TO GET THAT
MONEY BACK FROM THE COLONIAL
PIPELINE AND I THINK THE
GOVERNMENT SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWE
TO DO ANYMORE OF THESE BIG
MASSIVE PAYMENTS WITHOUT SOME
NEW MECHANISM TO GET THE MONEY
TO PEOPLE IN A MORE HONEST
FASHION.
THEY HAVE MORE MONEY
>> PEOPLE WHO ARE LAID OFF,
PEOPLE WHO CAN'T WORK BECAUSE
THEIR KIDS ARE NOT IN SCHOOL,
AND THEN YOU HAVE PPP LOANS THA
WERE ALSO SUBJECT TO MASSIVE
FRAUD AND CORRUPTION.
I JUST ONE OF THE MANY REASONS
WHY THERE ARE SO MANY PEOPLE OU
THERE WHO DO NOT TRUST THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
>> THAT IS VERY LIBERTARIAN OF
YOU AND I'M GOING HAVE TO AGREE
AT THIS PARTICULAR MOMENT.
>> JESSE ISN'T LIKE IT.
>> ANYTHING.
>> THE HOME STUDIO IS GREAT FEA
HIT.
>> I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR,
OBVIOUSLY 400 BILLION IS A TON
OF MONEY AND THE FACT THAT IT
WENT TO RUSSIA AND CHINESE
ACTORS MAKES IT EVEN WORSE, SO
WHAT CAN WE DO LOOKING FORWARD
TO ENSURE THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN?
I KNOW PEOPLE WHO GOT CHECKS WH
SHOULDN'T HAVE GOTTEN CHECKS, I
KNOW PEOPLE WHO SHOULD HAVE
GOTTEN JEX IF HE DIDN'T GET
THOSE CHECKS, WE NEED
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THIS AND
HOPEFULLY IT WILL BE RAISED WIT
PUGIN AND THEY WILL BE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE CHINESE
ABOUT THIS BECAUSE THERE IT
COULD GET THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN THE GOVERNMENT IS TOO BIG.
IT'S BIG, IT'S POWERFUL, THERE
ARE NO MORE CHECKS AND BALANCES
WHEN IT'S THAT MUCH OF A
BEHEMOTH BEAR TO GET COUNTRY IS
SO RICH THAT 400 BILLION CAN
BLOCK WALK OUT THE DOOR AND.
IT'S ON TRUMP AND BIDEN, THEY
ARE ALL ACCOUNTABLE FOR A.
IT'S A BREACH OF THE PUBLIC
TRUST.
IT'S A DISRESPECT TO THE
TAXPAYERS OF THIS MONEY, THERE'
NO SAFEGUARDS, THERE IS NO
MECHANISM TO PREVENT FRAUD TO
PREVENT ACCOUNTABILITY AND WHER
IS NANCY?
SHE IS IN CONTROL OF THE
PURSESTRINGS.
SHE'S THE SPEAKER THE HOUSE AND
CONTROLS WERE ALL THIS MONEY
GOES, SHE HASN'T SAID ANYTHING
ABOUT IT, IT'S LIKE SHE DOESN'T
MAKE HER BECAUSE SHE DOESN'T.
REMEMBER WHEN SHE FOUGHT TOOTH
AND NEIL TO DENY HIM TO BILLION
$400 BILLION WENT OUT THE DOOR
AND SHE IS SILENT.
>> GOOD LUCK GETTING THAT BACK.
INFLATION THOUGH.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WILL HIT
LOWER AND MIDDLE INCOME EARNERS
MORE THAN REPEALING THE 2017 TA
CUTS.
>> LIKE SOMETHING THAT SHRINKS.
>> YOU KEEP BRINGING UP RUSSIA
AND CHINESE AGENTS, I MEAN
ACTORS, WHAT ABOUT OUR ACTORS,
THAT CAN'T EVEN WORK RESTAURANT
BECAUSE THEY'RE CLOSED, WAIT
TABLES.
ANYWAY.
YOU WANT YOUR HEAD TO EXPLODE?
REMEMBER JOE BIDEN APPOINTED TH
PERSON TO OVERSEE THESE
PAVEMENTS WHO HAD THE SAME JOB
IN WASHINGTON STATE DURING WHIC
ALMOST I THINK ALMOST $1 BILLIO
WAS STOLEN, AND WHO WERE THEY
STOLEN BY?
NIGERIANS.
WE HAVE PEOPLE IN GOVERNMENT WH
GOT DEFRAUDED BY NIGERIAN
SCAMMERS.
I KNOW GRANDMOTHERS WHO AREN'T
GETTING DEFRAUDED BITE NIGERIAN
GRAMMARS AND PRINCES, THE FACT
THAT THIS PERSON WAS ABLE TO
FAIL UP, AND YOUR RIGHT, IT'S
ABUSE OF THE TAXPAYER, I DON'T
THINK THE DEMOCRATS VALUE MONEY
AS A BUREAUCRATS.
>> WHAT ABOUT MY BIT COIN
STRATEGY.
>> DEMOCRATS DON'T SEE MONEY,
THEY JUST SEE WHAT OTHER PEOPLE
'S MONEY AND IT'S NOT
THERE IS, IT'S LIKE THEY'RE
DRIVING BY A CAR ACCIDENT AND
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE DOING,
THEY'RE DRIVING BY $1 BILLION
HERE, SO IT'S NOT REALLY MONEY
BECAUSE IT'S NOT MINE, THAT IS
THE TAKE HOME AND IT'S
INFURIATING, BUT THINK ABOUT WH
HE HIRED.
>> WHO ACTUALLY RESEARCH FOR
THIS PREGNANT
SEGMENT.
I'M PROUD OF YOU.
>> CAN SOMEBODY IN THE CONTROL
ROOM GOOGLE IT?
>> CALIFORNIA HAS THE SAME
PROBLEM.
>> I DON'T KNOW HER NAME EITHER.
>> IT'